oh
tonight we are all afraid there have
been two mothers
in for Haunting in Venice we take the
bones of Agatha Christie's mystery the
book called Halloween party and put it
into Venice with all of these wonderful
actors to create the perfect haunting
mystery
it was very exciting to be a part of
this ongoing film Legacy of these
stories
[Music]
um
my character is Loosely based on Agatha
Christie poro I've found something she's
a spiritualist come with me to the
Halloween party we are invited to a
seance it's a treat to be in the Agatha
Christie world and everyone's really
supportive and we all come together and
the cameras are all up I love that I
love the theatrical side of it
doing the Skins can brought everyone
together as an ensemble it's very
collaborative the whole group had to be
very dramatic with different nuances
is someone there
[Music]
what is happening
with Ken thrifting it's very good we got
several together and we all just talk
these team bonding exercises and just
creates this real sense of a unit and a
company of actors and we're all in this
together
this is the beauty of having a big
Ensemble just have this connection and
this shared experience
so are you
all of these wonderful actors provide a
Humanity that is very touching and very
haunting
all of which confuses you and you are in
quite the conundrum as to who done it
for once in your life admit that you are
up against something bigger than you
[Music]
directed by Kenneth Branagh